the gyro can experience some doesn't a
room some some rooms are tightly
controlled in right but starting we
didn't always perform in tightly
controlled environment
oh yeah backyard bars bars yeah yeah
like there's so many other spots but you
also have to make comedy happen
yeah and those phases where there's a
big moat between you and the audience
Jackson jail strip club Jack and Jill
strip club in Woonsocket Rhode Island
there's a guy who sees you there's a guy
named Brian diri he used to book these
gigs I think still around he's to book
these gigs in Rhode Island and some of
them were great but occasionally they
were terrible and this one as far as I
know I think I was alone I think I was a
one-and-done okay I think they killed it
after either because it was only like
four people in the crowd and I went up
and it was a guy and a girl Jack and
Jill strip club is a there's an old
concept that didn't really take off
where couples would go and guy would go
and strip and the girl would go in strip
and they both look like their parents
drank while they were in the blue both
they're both had terrible tattoos this
guy had terrible tattoos and he had them
covered with bandanas so it like like
bandanas around his arm you can see like
the shitty tattoo poking out of the
bottom and he wasn't it was built goofy
he's built like a guy who like lifts
weights but he drinks every night I mean
like it wasn't wrong potbelly it wasn't
like if you go to Vegas and you see
those like the men from Down Under there
they're both disgusting they're both
disgusting and it was and I'd like to
say I bombed but bombing usually you
hear some noise right like people are
mad at you it was they were not even
recognizing that I was talking oh my god
so I got off stage and there was like a
little pool table in the back and there
was a dude who just happened to be in
town because his family lived there
because it was around the holidays and
his family lived in Rhode Island and he
just wanted to get out of the house so
he came to this local bar and any in he
goes hey what the [ __ ] is this place and
I go what are you doing here and he goes
I'm just here my [ __ ] family lives
around here and I just came here because
there's nowhere else to go
the [ __ ] is this place this is so
strange and he and I had a game of pool
when we were laughing that's hilarious
yeah I'll never forget it it was so
strange was so strange that's not a
controlled environment those gigs those
gigs seizing you though yes you you get
you you develop the crust yes a layer of
protection where you could go up in
front of those people yes and you also
know when you get offered those gigs
what it's gonna be like yeah just by the
tone I mean it's gonna be great as
always packed I was okay alright where
is it again sure there was some that
were always packed there was some gigs
he and I'd get old school shitty bar
gigs that were fun man
yeah they were wild they made me cuz
they fed me right those gigs fed me when
I was poor
[Applause]